Welcome to Ear Biscuits.
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week.
Boy, I've been waiting to say this again.
And I get to be the first one to say it,
'cause we alternate.
And the lot was cast to me
at the round table of dim lighting.
Why you looking at me like that?
I just want to make sure
you didn't screw it up.
Now you're making me nervous.
I want to make sure you
didn't screw it up, man.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting.
That's right.
We are at the round table of dim lighting.
We are back here with our
microphones, with our table,
with each other, talking
at each other's faces.
And appreciating the places
that have meant so much
to our creativity over the years.
Starting with this table.
I mean, I'm so glad to be back here.
In this spot, having this
conversation because,
just like we talked about with
Good Mythical Morning,
shooting on split screen, man.
I was gonna say that's overrated,
but we never rated it too highly
No, it's just it got old real quick.
It was nice to be back behind the desk.
It's nice to be back
behind the table, man.
Now, yeah, the days of,
well I'm gonna say the days,
that time period of USB audio
where people began to
complain about my breathing.
I noticed that people were
complaining about my breathing.
Well hopefully those days
are over for a while.
Huffing and puffing and dad noises.
We don't know what's gonna happen.
We don't know if there's
gonna be a second lockdown.
We don't know how this
whole thing's gonna unfold,
but we know that we are back in the space
that we wanted to be, and
now we are wearing headphones
and that is because Kiko,
who would normally be worrying about
all of this technical
stuff, is still in Texas.
So when he gets back,
I will go, I at least
will go back to my,
take the headphones off.
You're going and can-less
Let it all hang out.
But for now, this could all go wrong
because we turned all
these cameras on ourselves.
We turn the audio recorder on ourselves
and we are then going to be responsible
for putting the cards.
I think it's working.
Oh, they just make it so easy for us.
Mic made a video.
It was like walking two
toddlers through the process.
He almost used a baby voice.
He could have used a baby voice
and I would not have been offended
because I like things to be
made clear to me and Link.
I'm confident that
we've got it worked out.
And like I said, appreciating
being back in this space
has led to this conversation
that we want to have today,
which is the importance
of physical spaces,
to our creativity.
It was something that I
think we knew instinctively
or we had these impulses to build
an environment around
us that would enhance
our ability to do what we wanted to do.
But it took a while to really
come to grips with like,
okay, this is a legitimate exercise.
Yeah.
So we're going to take a
trip through memory lane
and trace the spaces through our career,
but also talk about some of the challenges
that we've experienced
because of how just unusual
the year 2020 has been,
and what that has meant for spaces.
But I did, I've been sitting on a story.
I've been sitting on a
story for a couple weeks now
that I've been wanting to tell you.
Let it loose, man.
So one of the things that Shepherd and I
do together is ride bikes.
We don't do it so often,
for me to say that it's our thing.
I know that you and Lincoln
have gotten into mountain biking together.
Yeah, he's not huge into it.
Every time I asked him to do
it he reluctantly says yes,
well not every, most of the time.
And Lando has a bike and
I'll take them biking.
I mean we all dreamed
about the idea of, as a dad
just being able to say,
"Hey, let's go do," fill in the blank.
And lights in our kids
eyes just turning on
and then being so excited
to go spend the day of adventure with dad.
Well that only happens in the movies.
And it probably happens in their memories
they're probably gonna remember it finally
but in the moment it's
like, "Do I have to go?"
When I mentioned riding a bike
the light goes off in their eyes.
Right.
What happened to us Link?
I don't know.
Video games.
But I have noticed that Lincoln,
as we're starting to allow
him to see some friends
in very controlled open air environments,
still with masks in the mix
and distancing fully intact.
He's riding his bike to meet his friends
and he and Locke hanging
out some and they're
hanging out outside and
doing some explorations
in the neighborhood and I'm like, yes.
Finally they're doing some of
the stuff that we used to do
Might get you hurt a little bit.
A little bit of innocent trespassing.
Well, let's not, yeah, maybe, maybe.
We don't know what they're doing.
There might be some fences
that lead to some--
I don't, we don't know.
Yeah, I don't know where they're going.
We're not going to talk about
it publicly, by any means.
But I was encouraged that
they're out on their bikes
meeting each other in like--
Right, just like Stand By Me.
They're gonna go find a dead body.
Well, don't spoil it for 'em.
Well you kinda learn
that right at the top.
Okay, good.
Also you can't spoil a movie
that's several decades old.
That an impossibility.
I know, I was just playing into the Link
You should watch it though.
And that, yes, that's one.
If you didn't think Ferris
Bueller would wow you,
Stand By Me is a different level of movie.
It is a intense, joyous, but sad.
I mean, it's just a beautiful,
beautiful movie, anyway.
You and Shepherd are biking.
So I decide to go biking with Shepherd
and this is the first time that we have,
you just watered your dog with your mug.
I didn't realize I was so full.
So we decided to go out,
and you know how it is.
I mean, for some reason,
when you make a decision
to be like, I'm going to go out
and I'm going to ride bikes with my son.
I'm going to take his
bike down from the place
You want it to be relatively easy.
You want to be like, okay
I'm gonna take his bike down
from the place that is
hanging in the garage,
and we're going to put it on the bike rack
and we're going to drive to the place
that we're going to bike.
But no, but of course, of course,
when I pull his bike down,
out of nowhere, his tires flat.
I knew you were gonna say that.
Do you remember ever having a
flat tire when we were kids?
No, but it's something--
California.
There's some California spurs.
Because I feel like I rode
the same bike tires and inner tubes.
Never once changed--
Like my entire childhood,
or at least when I got a bike
I kept that bike and those inner tubes.
Never had it, I had to pump
up the tires occasionally.
Let me tell you jack.
Tell me jack.
There were some sand spurs
back in North Carolina too.
But we never hit 'em.
I don't know what it is.
But yes, okay, so had
to patch the inner tube,
because I didn't have a replacement.
Of course this requires
taking the wheel off.
And then I got to put it back on.
It was the front tire,
thankfully, a little bit easier.
And then we're like, okay.
And I kind of got mad at that point.
Did you invite Shepherd to
help you patch the tire?
Because that's a dad choice.
I thought about it.
All right son, you know what we're gonna
learn to patch a tire together,
because I don't know how to do it either,.
No, I do know how to do it
because I've had to do it
like five times since
living in California.
But he was, like I got the bike down.
I was like, "Oh man, you got a flat tire."
And he was like, "Okay,
I'm going upstairs.
"Let me know when you're ready."
And then I was just like,
okay, I'm not, I don't
want to fight him here.
Because I'm having to
fight him to go ride bikes.
If you force him to change it,
he's not gonna ride it with you.
So let me, 'cause this is a key point,
I'm already a little bit in a bad mood.
Fix the bike, put the bike on the rack.
We go to the place that
we're going to ride.
And Shepherd's already complaining.
He's like, "Dad, my bike hurts me
"and my legs get cramped, is too small."
And I'm like, "Okay, well, first of all,
"it's not that small."
"And if you can go out
"and do the things that
I'm asking you to do today,
[Link And Rhett Together]
I'll get you a new bike.
I've been through all of this too.
I mean, all of the flat
tires, all of the bribery.
Promising new bikes.
Yeah.
And so I said,
"Shepherd, the thing that
we're going to concentrate on
"today is you being able
to stand up and pedal."
because he'll do it, but he
doesn't quite get his weight,
he's really using his quads,
and I'm trying to get him to understand,
standing up while riding your
bike is how you get power.
It's how you go up hills.
This is a quintessential skill set
that I'm trying to pass on to my kids.
And by the time I was
11 years old, of course,
I could stand up on a bike
because all we did was ride bikes around.
But the only time that we
ride bikes as a family,
is when we ride bikes as a family,
You know what I'm saying.
It's like he's not riding his
bike around the neighborhood.
I don't know exactly know why
it's probably because
we've got so many hills
and it would be really difficult.
But anyway, we get out there--
Specially if you can't stand up.
And we're in a relatively flat area.
But instead of taking the
concrete path or the paved paths
that we would normally
take around this big area.
I was like, let's go down
into some of these
little trails and stuff.
It's not like a mountain
biking area necessarily.
It's more of a walking area,
but mountain bikes are allowed.
And I just noticed really early on
that Shepherd is lagging behind.
And so I'll get ahead
of him then I'll go back
and be like, "All right, Shepherd,
"you got to keep up with
me, I mean this is flat."
I mean, there's nothing.
"This isn't hard." I kept saying,
I was like, "This is not hard.
"We haven't gotten to anything hard yet."
He was like--
I can make it hard if you want.
If you want to make this
difficult, I can do it.
I wasn't there yet.
And he was like, "Well,
it's hot, and this is hard."
And he kept having to stop
and then he would stop and
he would push his bike,
like on a flat surface, and I was like,
"Shepherd, you're not getting a new bike."
It's like I was like,
"You're not listening to me.
"You're not standing up.
"You're not doing any of the
stuff that I asked you to do.
"And so I'm not getting you a new bike."
And then he just had this look of defeat.
I felt bad.
But I was also like, I was texting Jessie.
Tough love, you went with tough Love.
I was texting Jessie
and I was like, "We got to do something.
"We got to send him to
bike school or something
because Dad is failing.
"I don't know what to do."
I'm feel like I'm losing control.
I know some bikes schools,
if you want me to write them down for you,
And then we get to this long straightaway
There's a bike school.
This probably is one.
Shepherd, I'm like,
There's this long
straightaway, and I'm like,
"Shepherd, okay, there's no excuse
"for you not being able to ride on this.
"It's almost like
concrete, there's no sand.
'Cause he was complaining
about the sandy parts
and then I just, I was
like, I was thinking,
what is the fatherly thing to do here?
What is the thing that he will remember?
And so I thought about
what happened with you
when you got drunk in high school.
What's that got to do with this?
Well in how I dropped you off
and made you walk, and then
I came back to meet you.
Okay.
I didn't really formulate this plan.
It kind of just came to me in the moment
and then I was like, okay,
I'm going to leave him
on this straightaway.
I'm just going to bike
and I'm not going to look back
and I'm going to disappear.
Eat my dust, kid.
I'm going to disappear
and I'm going to see
if he's gonna react,
if he's gonna respond,
if he's gonna grab hold of this moment.
Stand up and pedal.
And bike on this path.
So I go, it's a long way
I go a long way.
Just so you do know what you seem like
to everyone listening
at this point, right?
Listen--
A tyrant
No, I'm not a tyrant
I know that--
It was an opportunity for growth.
I know the feeling, I'm with
you, but everybody's not.
And I was giving him an
opportunity to respond, right?
You think I'm a tyrant?
Let me tell you some of the
stories about what my dad.
I told you that I learned
how to swim in the river
when my dad threw me into the river.
Yeah, that makes it all okay.
Okay, but no, I'm like, if my dad's a ten,
I'm a one when it comes to this.
That's not true, but okay.
So I--
You're ditching him.
I drive off, or ride off.
Do you drive a bike?
Are you in a car this whole time?
You left that detail out.
I mean, I'm commanding the bike.
I'm not just riding on
it, I am driving it.
And I don't know the proper term,
I disappear over the horizon.
And then I stopped under a tree and wait.
And then I go back
around this a little bend
and I look and he is pushing
that bike, and I am just
not happy about it.
Livid.
But at this point, I
was like, I just can't,
I can't do anything
I can't break his spirit anymore.
You could go back to the car
and leave him there permanently,
if you want to abandon your son.
So I go to him and I say,
"Shepherd, I don't know
what happened today
"but we got to get back to the car."
And so we start pushing the bikes.
And I'm still thinking about
like fatherly things to say and
how do I send a message here?
How do I give him an
opportunity to want to,
I'm thinking about preserving
his desire to bicycle.
You know what I'm saying?
We're in that state at this point.
And so I'm like, you know
what, he's going very slow.
I'm like, "Let me push your bike.
"I'll push both of our bikes #
"and all you have to do is walk."
So I put my bike in one hand,
I grab his bike in the other hand,
and I begin to walk with it
and two seconds into
walking with this bike
I'm like, something is
wrong with his bike.
Oh, it is the tire isn't it?
Is it the tire?
And it's my fault.
You patched.
No, no, no.
When I patched the front tire.
You dis-patched.
I put it on.
I pumped it up.
And I, you spin the wheel
to make sure that the brake
is not catching, right?.
But something happened between
putting the bike on the rack
and then giving him the bike
that his front brake was catching.
And so the reason he couldn't do anything
is because it was almost like he was
going up a hill the whole
time, regardless of the slope,
because he had this
resistance in the front brake.
And I was like, "Shepherd,
you bike is messed up, man.
"Your front brake is catching
"That is why you've had
such a hard time today."
And I was like,
"Man, I am so sorry for everything
that I just said to you.
"I thought that you"--
But you should have found it.
You should have noticed.
I said, "I thought that you
had just completely given up."
And I was like, he's been
playing too many video games.
He's lost his ability to be
outside, I've created a monster.
And then he's laughing, now
we're laughing at each other.
And I'm like, "Shepherd,
this is just a sign
"that we need to ride
bikes more because you
"couldn't perceive that something
was wrong with your bike.
"And as soon as I touched it,
"I knew that there was something wrong.
"We gotta ride bikes more.
I said, "You know what,
"when we get home, I'm gonna
pick you out a new bike."
So we went home--
But we're gonna break it
and you have to figure out what's broken.
Oh, my story's not done.
Oh, dang.
I buy a new bike and--
Yeah, 'cause you offered the old bike.
Rhett text me
And he's like, "Hey, does
this Lando need a bike?
"I'm getting Shepherd a bigger one
"'cause he's too small for
this one, maybe Lando?"
And you sent me a picture of it.
But you didn't tell me that it was bunk.
It's not, no, no, that it's my fault.
It just needs the brakes,
the front brakes need to be adjusted.
It's a good bike, it's a Trek.
I don't want that bike.
So I do have a bike available
for anybody who wants it.
So we get a new bike.
And you had bought your
bike at the local bike shop,
which is what I wanted to do.
Support local business.
But I decided not to do that
because I didn't want to,
I'm trying not to go in places.
I'm still not even going
into grocery stores
Call me crazy, but we're still--
I wouldn't call you crazy.
I would just call you a
bad dad and a bad shopper.
Right.
We're trying to maintain,
because we're coming into the office
and we're working with each other
and then working with a
very small group of people,
everyone who's doing that
we're just trying to maintain essentially
an isolation until we
come and work together.
So everybody knows, hey, we're safe.
So I'm not really going into any place.
And well,
so I ordered the bike online,
and I don't know, I've
never bought a bike online.
I thought this means--
Some dudes gonna ride up on your body
Yeah, I thought UPS man just rode up,
put the kickstand down and gave it to you.
There is no kickstand didn't
get that kind of bike.
That's not what happens.
A box shows up.
And it's called a box build,
which is most of the bike
has been put together but
some very key elements
like the front fork is
not attached to the frame.
This is a, and that's kind of a key part
of the whole process, right?
Oh man.
And I called the local bike shop
and I was like, "I just
got this bike in a box."
He was like, "Yeah,
it's called a box build.
Hundred dollars and we're a month out."
Oh, gosh.
Apparently everyone's doing this.
And you could you could sense
bitterness in his voice,
'cause he's like, "You jackass.
"You went and bought it online.
"You could have just bought it from us.
And you know, it probably
isn't even a month wait.
I called another bike shop.
They were like, "We're a month out."
It's like it's the thing you'd say.
Punitive.
Tell 'em it's a month out.
DId you think about returning it
and just getting one from the local?
No, I said, well I'm gonna build it.
Oh, okay.
I have YouTube.
I actually make a living on it.
I brought up a YouTube video.
And at this point, you had a dad choice
to include Shepherd in
the building of his bike.
I knew that I did not need Shepherd
to witness what was going to happen.
Knowing how easily this could go wrong?
It was gonna be ugly.
Seven minutes in I break it.
I'm trying to attach
the thing to the thing.
And I'm tightening it down
and then there's a little cap
that goes on top of your
dilly dally, and it broke.
Can I ask you?
You can ask me anything you want.
When this happens,
Yes I curse.
Are you a audible curser,
or are you a mumbler?
Are you a silent cursor?
I think all of the above.
So you do go to audible cursing range?
Oh, yes.
And is it like, full on?
No, it's not.
Are you going like, f bombs?
Well, yeah, but I'm not, but
it's more I've just like,
I don't do that.
I'll be like, and I'm
very critical of myself
when I make a mistake.
I'm lying, I've done that.
And I'm like, "Rhett, you f-ing idiot."
I'll say things like that to
myself, because I'm just like,
"You shouldn't have done this
box built in the first place.
"And now you've screwed it up."
I hate that feeling, it's
worse when it's a car,
which I know we've both also done
in our early days of marriage.
We thought we would impress our wives
by fixing our own cars.
Yeah, I totaled a car one time.
Engineering degrees do not help
with practical things like building bikes.
And let me tell you,
the YouTube videos were
not helpful at all.
At least the ones that I watched.
So newsflash, I had to take
the bike to the bike shop.
Oh man, talk about the walk of shame.
And, of course, first of all,
I haven't been in a public place.
So I, like there's, the
bike shop that we go to,
there's an open door,
then there's the counter.
And so I go and I look in there
and there's like three
people in the bike shop.
Everybody's got on masks.
They're all standing really far apart.
And I just stand in the doorway
until the guy helps the
people and he comes to me
I'm like, "Box build, I screwed it up.
"I need you to do it."
He's like, "You know,
it'll be a month out."
"Yes, I know, it'll be a month."
"Did I tell you how much?"
"Hundred bucks I know, yeah."
And then I said, "Is there's no way
"I could pay extra to get it faster?"
He's like, "Ah, we've done
that a couple of times.
"And I can't make any promises.
"And also you end up
doubling your investment
"in what you paid for this."
At that point he was just trying,
he was pushing me off of it.
And I was like, "Okay, just
let me know when you're done."
I'll shamefully walk back in here.
And get a bike for my son
and then go bond with him.
Meanwhile, has he been
watching YouTube videos
on how to stand up and bike?
That's not how it works,
you got to just do it.
We'll you still got the old bike.
Yeah, I do, but I have to fix that.
I mean, it wouldn't be that hard to do,
but I just, I'm so mad at that bike.
Are you mad at the bike,
or you mad at someone else?
It's one of those things that
when you're in the midst of quarantine,
and I think that everyone,
the thing that we've been noticing is
the family has just never been
around each other this much.
Oh gosh, I know it.
And you're just like,
usually there would be
somebody would go somewhere,
like a kid would go
someplace, school or anything.
I've just learned that
going places and interacting
and doing other things,
really, even if you're an introvert,
there's got to be a certain level of
at least getting away from
the people in your home
that then it's nice to realize
those more world than just
the people in your own home.
I mean, the thing that
resonates with me is
the first week of quarantine
I'm getting water and ice
out of the friggin fridge and
there's no ice in the whole,
my ice makers broken.
I haven't had ice the whole time.
This whole time?
Because I didn't want to call someone
to come in the house and fix it's
It's like the 1700s with your house.
We had, we're pouring ice
into the little things
and then not refilling it,
but leaving it in there
so that when someone goes for ice
and it's just an empty tray
with no water or ice in it,
everybody gets upset.
And then all this winds coming through.
And I look outside yesterday and the tree
in front of my house, the
little tree that staked down.
It's like a seven foot tall
tree, but still pretty thin.
It's blown over because
the stake that was holding it up broke.
And here I am, I can't,
I'm trying to like re-stake the tree,
and I can't even do it.
Like we're not men anymore, man.
We can't do stuff that we thought that
you're supposed to be,
oh, the tree fell over
or the bikes in a box.
That's fine.
My son is a disappointment,
I can fix this.
I did do plumbing, I did
plumbing this past weekend.
You did plumbing?
The garbage disposal had
come loose and was leaking.
You tightened something.
Well no, it fell off completely.
Oh wow.
And I did, and I watched
a YouTube video for that
and I got to a place where
I was about to tell Jessie
we have to call a plumber.
But I did it, I did it and
I was so proud of myself.
It feels good, but it's just hard.
It's hard to actually get stuff done
and not screw it up.
I mean, kids included.
Everybody's fuse is a little bit shorter.
And it's gonna take some kind of,
like I know we're both
thinking about doing
some kind of vacation, like
local, somewhere in California
maybe taking a vacation
at some point, but boy.
It might be five separate vacations.
I think we need that.
I'm gonna call it a firework vacation
where it's like, "Okay, go."
And then everybody just goes
in a different direction.
call that the firework.
Yeah, how do you take a vacation and then
just leave your kid somewhere,
We got to start figuring that out.
I think all of this, again,
really brings me back to appreciating
the spaces that we haven't
been able to enjoy,
like being back here and our offices
and stuff like that, which is
what we want to talk about.
So we'll get to it.
But first, we're going to
give you an opportunity
to just spy the shirt
that Link is wearing.
You might remember that
was a there was a time,
there was a time on
this particular podcast
where we would answer your questions
and then we would leave you
with a little catchphrase.
Good luck with that.
And we kind of thought
that it was gonna become
the thing that we said.
In fact, we got a mug that had it on it.
We gotta start saying it
again because it's on this T.
[Rhett} And then we develop this--
It's the Randler.
Version of the Randler.
With he mythical logo.
And now we know that the tie dye thing is,
everybody loves to tie dye.
So now if you want to get the tie dye
good luck with that T
shirt featuring the Randler
you need to go to mythical.com
to make that a reality.
You like it Jade?
Take it from Jade.
What you looking at?
Go back down.
She's like, I've never
seen things from this view.
Mythical.com.
Okay.
Were we still going?
That was a very pregnant pause.
Yeah, had to push it out.
You actually thought
of talking about space?
Why did you do that?
What made you think about spaces?
Well...
Me and Lincoln building the thing?
Well, no, it was the fact
that we were coming back.
It was twofold.
Yeah, what we talked about,
but what's the other fold?
It was that yesterday.
Was that yesterday?
Yeah.
We were over in the creative house.
And the creative house,
what the vision for the creative house
of being decorated and moved in.
Of course, the virus also
infected that process.
Yeah it did.
Really slowed it down.
But furniture for different
parts of the house,
including the living room,
and then some stuff in
your office came in.
And Link and Lincoln were
putting some of it together.
And so I was just
thinking about, it's funny
because we designed this
space here for ourselves.
I mean, we didn't design this space
that we're in right now, necessarily.
We took advantage of the
fact that it was like
an awesome recording studio
that happened to be here at
the space we were renting.
But we designed our space for our office.
And then, we've talked about this already,
but how we came to the conclusion
that we needed our own space again,
ironically, because this
space doesn't necessarily say,
"Hey, Rhett and Link, create."
It says "Hey, Rhett and Link."
"Have meetings.
"You're business boys."
"Supervise and be business boys."
And so giving this
other space where it was
a new zone where we
could express ourselves.
And we knew that that first
meant setting it up it.
Because we have a long
history of setting up spaces.
I mean I'll go all the
way back to college.
We really started to appreciate
having our own space.
I mean that, remember how exciting it was
when we moved in to our
dorm room at NC State.
And I remember the first
few weeks of school
you're walking around the quad
and you're going to classes.
And do you remember this?
All of these vendors had set up.
They were selling crap, mostly posters.
You remember this?
They were selling posters
all over the quad.
And there were huge
posters, little posters.
Mostly just band posters
and cool movie poster.
And they knew that college
students who were just
moving into their dorm
rooms would just go bananas.
Oh yeah, it's like, oh, Bob Marley.
So many Bob Marley posters.
I kind of felt like I needed
to get a Bob Marley poster
just because it seemed
like the thing to do.
But instead we got a pulp fiction poster
where Vincent Vega and--
Jules.
Jules were, I think it's
after they were shot at
and miraculously didn't get hit
and they just opened fire.
Yeah, the scene with Brad.
And then we also bought a
meeting, a poster of a meeting
between Elvis, who seemed to be in his--
Last days.
On his last legs, meeting President Nixon.
And I actually don't know
the story behind that poster.
Well the story behind that poster is--
I just thought, okay, it's kind of cool.
No, it was a, I'm gonna get
some of these details wrong.
But my understanding is that
it was an anti-drug meeting.
That's what makes it so funny.
It was an ironic poster
And I think that they
may have even made Elvis
like an honorary DEA officer or something.
I don't know how the legend goes,
but they had been talking about drugs.
And of course, Elvis obviously
had been using a lot of drugs.
And you've got Nixon in his
suit and Elvis in his suit,
which is a very different kind of suit.
Yeah.
We loved that poster, man.
Yeah, and I didn't even know
the full story behind it.
And I just thought it was odd and ironic.
I could sense the irony.
I didn't have to, it didn't
have to be explained to me.
That's where we got Mr
Fly from the thrift store,
The velour couch that then
we would pose like Lionel,
and made project Lionel.
And then we decorated the
wall with pictures of Lionel.
I mean, if you don't know the story,
you can get it in the book of Mythicality.
But it was just so exciting
to have this space,
this hideout, this little dungeon space.
I mean, we had no light coming in,
our window was right under
the steps to the first floor.
And it was pitch dark
in the broad daylight.
All the time, which is good for college
because you can just
sleep in the middle of day
and it feels like night.
And it smelled like a basement.
I like that smell.
It was very dank in that sense.
And then we moved to
an apartment with Greg.
And then the next year
is when Tim moved in too,
but the apartment was like,
whoa, it's not just one room now.
We don't just have to
have this little fridge.
I think it was Lily that ask me about it,
and she was like,
"What did you have in your
dorm room to cook with?"
And I was like,--
Toaster oven and microwave.
We had a dorm fridge with a
microwave sitting on top of it
and then a toaster oven
sitting on top of that
the triple threat that's all you needed.
They should make that as one unit
that they sell for college kids.
That's a good idea.
It's probably a huge fire hazard though.
And also like it'll--
Fridge, microwave, toaster oven.
Too much amps.
I'd love to have a fridge
that you could just put
bread into the side of
and it pop out toast, that's pretty cool.
It's a toaster fridge, it's a good idea.
What it is It's a fridge
that's got a toaster and a microwave.
And when you place your hand
on one of the objects
in the fridge, it knows
whether to send it to the
toaster oven or microwave.
And then on top of that
it's got like a humidifier
or one of those,
what's those vaporizer
things that our wives
put around our house
and I'm addicted to it.
Yeah, a vaporizer.
That makes nice smell.
That seems unnecessary.
That feels like maybe that
it's in the deluxe package
Deluxe package, man.
Yeah, you gotta sell them up.
We're gonna put that on mythical.com.
Take notes, self.
But we always thought, and
this is, we weren't seeing it
as a creative space at the
time, we were seeing it
as a space to live in
and express ourselves.
But we ran coaxial cable to connect
multiple televisions in multiple rooms
so that we could have people over
and watch movies in
multiple rooms at once.
Well, and we had the
Planet of the Apes party,
if I recall correctly.
I don't know if we've
ever told this story.
I'm sure we have.
But we got this idea
that we were going to invite
every woman
every woman that we saw on campus.
This is sounding like a you and Greg idea.
It was definitely me and Greg.
I mean I was dating Christie.
So I was like, I had to
wash my hands of this plot.
So Greg and I were like,
All right, what we're gonna do is--
But I was interested.
When you see a group of women on campus,
you just walk up to them and you say,
"Hey, we're having a
Planet of the Apes party.
3000 C, Gorman Crossings.
Friday night, 7 p.m. whatever we said.
Bring whoever you want.
Yeah.
Now keep in mind that--
They're like, Planet of the Apes party?
It's like, yeah, we're gonna
watch Planet of the Apes.
Don't matter what room
in the house you're in.
You'll be watching it in
sync with every one else.
'Cause every TV would be
playing Planet of the Apes.
Now, let me just say a couple of things.
We're talking about the
original Planet of the Apes,
because the new ones hadn't come out yet.
Charlton Heston.
And we weren't,
because we were
involved in the Campus
Crusade campus ministry,
as we've talked about extensively.
We weren't drinking.
So there was going to be no alcohol.
But not only was there
going to be no alcohol,
there was going to be no anything.
Like no dr--
And actually, this was
part of the experiment.
Do you remember this?
I showed up late.
No, no.
I didn't help plan it, no pun intended.
Me and Greg, it's almost like me and Greg,
thought that it would be
like a social experiment.
It's so stupid.
To not provide food or drink?
No food, no drink, just
Planet of the Apes.
That's so stupid.
Worse party ever.
I mean, if you take care of
the big things at a party,
the little things take care of themselves.
Yeah.
Like if you got a bunch of strangers.
I was going to say a
bunch of strange women,
but women that you don't know.
You only invited women
and then they can invite
anybody they want,.
'Cause if you invite women,
men will show up, I mean--
They'll come out of the woodwork
Well, it because we knew
that our dude friends are gonna show up.
But first of all, I don't believe
that any of the women that we didn't know
who we just randomly asked on campus came.
I don't believe any of them came.
I think they saw through,
this isn't a typical
Planet of the Apes party.
No food, No drink.
No, you know, no fun.
They probably won't let
us even use the restroom.
I don't, no one use the restroom.
No need for it if you're not drinking.
But it was so--
There was a lot of people there though.
You knew that it was kooky.
It was just, I mean, is
that a fair word to say?
It was just like so, it
was intentionally odd.
Yeah.
And so it gave you the confidence.
If I'm to go up to
strange women on campus,
because it was just like, this is weird.
So me going up to someone
I don't know is less weird
than what I'm going to
say once I get up there.
So it's was like,
you had to work up, once
you worked or the gumption
to have the party, inviting
strangers was easy.
It's kind of brilliant.
Well I'm glad you think that
because I never thought of it that way.
But then the execution.
You had, the whole thing was
a plot to work yourself up
to talk to strange women.
But if it had been a good
party, and like memorable.
It would have happened again.
There's more Planet of the Apes movies.
Yeah, well, that was the idea.
Let's show the first
one, see what happens.
I don't recall it ever happening again.
But it was a disaster.
You're not, we're not really talking about
the space beyond the coaxial cables,
going from room to room
and not well hidden.
But also at that time that our idea
of what a space was going to
be was so like college dudes.
It didn't matter
the washer and dryer were in the kitchen.
In the kitchen, yeah.
I was doing the laundry when
I saw that giant ass rat
come out from underneath the refrigerator.
Yeah, very scary.
But our first workspace was not really
that great of a space because
when after engineering,
there was the stint
working with Campus Crusade
at the regional office.
We were working in cubicles.
We went into a meeting room
and we would set up a camera
and we would whisper into a microphone.
And those are our first videos.
But it wasn't our own space.
It wasn't, and you know, and
so we wanted our own space.
It was around this time
that, with Campus Crusade,
since we were, we had special roles.
It's like we would
travel and we would speak
and we were like, resident videographers
and all the things we
talked about, like MCs
and sketch artists, comedian guys .
Sketch artists.
That's a completely different.
Yes, not in that way.
There was a conference that they put on
just for the creative
types within Campus Crusade
and we were, and this was
a national conference.
Where they pulled together
everybody from all the regions.
Creativity Summit.
Called the Creativity Summit,
because when you're in a campus ministry,
and or maybe this is true
of any kind of group,
but they like to put on conferences.
Oh, yeah.
And we got, it was an invitation only.
Most of the people who
worked in the organization,
they worked on campus.
They didn't, they weren't
the creative type,
like a graphic designer, or
a speaker, or a filmmaker,
videographer type like we were.
So we were invited to this thing.
It was in conjunction with a film festival
out here in Los Angeles.
Du Mar.
This was our first trip to Los Angeles.
Super exciting.
I mean, we started meeting
other creative types from other regions.
It was very cool.
It was very inspiring.
And then they had speakers to talk about
cultivating and legitimizing
creativity because
our roles and everyone who was there,
their roles were kind of on the fringe
of what the main type
of job descriptions were
with the organization.
But I remember one guy
talking and he might have been
a former like Disney Imagineer.
He was and he's in that
documentary Imagineering.
Oh, really?
Yeah, 'cause he was at Disney forever.
I remember specifically, they talked about
something that seems so
obvious, and it's exactly
what we're talking about now,
it's the importance of space
to foster creativity.
And like I said, even though
we had this instinct of like,
I made hideouts as a kid, and like,
my ex stepdad, Jimmy, we
built that tree house,
and you and I would hang out back there.
It's like having your own
space where it's like,
I can cook things up and
I can do my own thing,
that was part of who we were.
We came back from that knowing
that the cramped little
office that we were
secluding ourselves in was not adequate
for the creative ideas
that we had specifically.
And it gave us permission,
that guy gave us permission
to want to have a space that
was conducive for creativity.
Well, and the B-hags
because he's the one who told us about
the big hairy, audacious goals.
Also Scott Derrickson was it
that film festival and spoke.
That's right.
Filmmaker Scott Derrickson.
Yeah, he directed Doctor Strange.
He directed a lot of horror movies.
So yeah, so we get back.
And that's when we know we need a space.
And I knew that my father in law had this,
the basement underneath
his, what at the time
was his business headquarters
for his dentistry.
And you saw this in the L tat video
and we went back to North Carolina,
and you weren't able to go,
but I kind of, it was open.
So I went in there.
But that was the beginning of us
having a space that was
intentionally a creative space.
And that's where so many of the aesthetics
of early Rhett and Link stuff.
See a a lot of this has
remained to this day.
The checkered floor, which incidentally,
somebody said on YouTube, that
was like a Illuminati thing.
Oh, give me a break.
No, no, no.
I mean, I like playing into it.
So yeah, it's an Illuminati thing.
That's why we have the checkered floor.
Give me a break, don't
even think about it.
The original green, I think about it.
The original green, Rhett and Link green.
Well, I think we--
It was really for green screen.
We painted a wall green screen,
and then we painted the other wall blue
just so we could have
a different background.
Because you can do blue screen,
you can do green screen.
It depends on what color you're wearing.
And that's when I started
collecting those Merle Haggard albums.
And we put them around
the front office room.
And since then, everywhere
we've had an office,
we've moved my collection of mural albums.
They're in the office right there now.
Well, and there was, it's
funny because there were
basically all the elements
that we've now always tried
to recreate, were technically,
if you think about it,
we're in that space, right?
You've got a workspace
where me and you have desks together.
And can develop the ideas.
We've got a place where we shoot
the things that we're doing.
We've got a studio space,
which it wasn't it was just another room.
That was the back room with
no windows, which was nice.
And we had a recording booth, right?
And because music was such
a big part of everything
that we were doing at that time,
so we turned an old closet
into a recording booth.
It was just nice to be able to go there.
And if anybody else stepped in, it's like,
immediately, this is weird, like, what,
in the middle of Harnett County.
People would step in.
Some people would show up
and knock on the on the door,
because it was like a Records Office,
it was a government records office.
It was right next to the DWI center.
Right.
So if someone who had
gotten a DWI had to then,
the county made them report to this place
where they would get help.
And many of them thought
that we were the DWI center.
We didn't treat anyone, that
would have been irresponsible.
We would just send them next door.
Next door, yeah.
But whenever we stepped in,
I remember this feeling of
we can do whatever we want.
It was just this exciting
level of freedom.
Well, I think there's a pressure
that comes too, I think.
And an expectation that like,
all right, we set this up how we want it.
You set the space up.
If we can't start making stuff,
if we don't make stuff it's our own fault.
And we made stuff.
Oh, yeah.
And I think that that, getting
the space that we needed,
that was one of the most, I mean,
not in terms of the amount of content,
because now we create more
content than we ever did.
And it's sort of steadily increased.
But that was sort of the beginning of us
being very prolific in
terms of the amount of stuff
we were working on and creating.
No one that we saw on YouTube had a space.
And everything we shot,
if you watch our videos,
you would get to know
everything in the space because
we shot everything there or
on the street outside of it.
Just look at the Facebook
song music video, you'll see,
the street corners of
Lillington, North Carolina.
But on YouTube it was younger
people, in their bedrooms,
shooting vlogs, shooting stuff like that.
It was it, no one was doing it.
No one that I knew of
was set up in that way.
And I mean, I couldn't imagine that.
I mean, I have kids at home,
if I was gonna act like a fool,
I couldn't do it at home
because there's babies crying.
Well I do think that's a,
we can jump, we can jump
forward and then jump back.
But to contrast that, there's
been a few times in our lives
where we've had to involuntarily
step back into a restricted space.
And I think that the two times
that I think about most are
well, I guess three times.
Moving to California, right?
'Cause there was the
studio space in Fuquay,
that was after the one in Lillington,
which was another big space.
That was even bigger.
But then, and it had high ceilings.
And no toilets above us.
But we moved to California.
We were working with, who
became our good friends,
Joke and Biagio at Joke Productions
who produce Commercial Kings.
And then we talked them
into letting us have
a little office in their production studio
because we were just living
in these furnished apartments
and had nowhere to work.
But that was a,
again, a constriction on the space
It was kind of like individual
edit bays in a high rise.
That's exactly what it was.
Yeah.
So we were in this
basically windowless room
with a couple of desks
that like, okay, you come
in and you work on this show
for a few weeks or months
and then you're gone,
and someone else will work here next time.
It was, it wasn't a
lot of character there.
But you know, that we were--
We were under a lot of pressure,
But the thing I remember,
the most significant thing
that we created at that time.
And again, it's just, it's pretty obvious
looking back that this
constriction of the space
sort of pressurized.
Just the location was small.
And we came up with
the, what did when we--
Caption fail.
Caption fail, the Caption Fail series,
which was a little bit of a--
They were filmed around there, yeah.
A little resurgence for us on YouTube.
Because we were able to
get a couple out quickly.
But I think that, there's
no doubt in my mind,
that that came from being in this place
like we can't make a music
video really right now.
The only music video I made was
we made the Harry Potter song,
which I'm super proud of that song
because I remember that
we worked all night on it.
It was one of the few times
that we worked all night on something
in order to turn it
around because we needed.
The reason why we made
that song is because
the last Harry Potter movie was coming out
and we were trying to
jump on that bandwagon
and get the views from it,
in order then to attach an
ad for Commercial Kings,
so that we can get more
people to watch our TV show.
And it,
I mean, it got a lot of views.
And it was shot right there
in basically the room
where we were working.
The ideas fit the setting.
But when we showed up at that place,
it was like this is not, I mean.
Wasn't our space.
It wasn't our space.
And it really there was like a desperation
of what we were just trying
to find our way again.
Especially once the show got canned.
Well, and then once we
decided to, and this is,
I've never really tracked
the content to the space.
But we got our own space again,
I mean own space, using that very loosely
because it wasn't anything
compared to what we had
in North Carolina when we decided that
the converted garage, or the guest house
in my backyard would be our new studio.
And that's where Good
Mythical Morning was born.
And in a really small,
I mean, I don't know.
what that room was, and maybe,
it was a two car garage.
It was the size of this room basically.
And it was the two of
us and Jason in there,
working on top of each other.
And then there was a time,
there was a few months,
because it was also a guest house.
Like when people came to stay with us,
they would stay in there.
With the relatives and then Antonio.
Antonio.
When he first moved out,
stayed in there for like,
a couple of months,
Did he, he slept on our couch, that couch.
Yes.
The couch would lay down like a futon.
But we said like, "Hey, we
gotta, you gotta be out of here
"before we get to work every morning
"because there's not
enough room physically
"for the futon, and you,
and all of us to be here."
Right.
Yeah, so it was--
There was a bathroom with a shower,
so that's why he was able to stay there.
But we also had the yard too.
And that's where dope zebra
happened in that backyard,
several other things that we shot
happened in that backyard.
The graduation song.
Because we've been, it's like,
there's a really good book
by the Duplass brothers.
I can't remember what it is.
I think we may have wrecked it.
But basically, they talk about their story
and their creative process.
And there's a lot of parallels
between the way that they
work with each other.
And the way that we've worked together.
But they talk about
the way that they approach
independent filmmaking,
and it was to find the space for the film,
to find the location and be like,
okay, we can go to this town.
This town has a sheriff's office,
and a gymnasium, and a library.
All right, let's write a screenplay
where these locations are featured.
So they let the space
dictate the screenplay.
And that's where a lot of their,
And that's why it was cheap.
And that's why they were
able to make a lot of money
off of those, or get going,
because they could actually make it.
And that's sort of an extreme example.
But I think that at each point,
the constriction of the space,
or the openness of the space,
has then contributed to
what we were working on
and what we were doing.
Well, when you talk about
openness, it makes me
want to skip ahead to this
studio space here, which,
I mean, when you look at
both sides of the studio,
and we got like, well, not all 80 people
are working in here,
and of course, nobody's
working in here now.
And who knows, but we got this open space
where most everybody's
working and there's enclaves
and offices where people can go in to meet
and have more private conversations,
and we have our office
back here in the back.
But even this conversations is
helping me really understand
what we already knew instinctively.
To really get creative, we needed to
step out of this space,
because it wasn't doing for us
what all the previous spaces did.
And what this space did at first.
Hmm, yeah.
Maybe it actually didn't, I mean.
Well, I think that, again,
this isn't necessarily directly creative,
but what this space allowed,
and then what the next door space allowed,
is, again, I feel like
the decisions about the space have driven
the specific decisions about what we do.
So we got this space.
We told the story on the
Dell sponsor podcast,
we told the history of the business.
And we told the story of Ben saying,
"I know that this place
is beyond our budget,
"but I want to let you
know that I think that
"we can take advantage of it.
"I think that this is the right place.
"I think we can use it."
And we took a chance,
and we moved in here,
not having any idea how we
would fill it with a team.
But again, you naturally fill the space.
And so yes, we did some
good creative work.
We've done a lot of good
creative work in this space.
But I think that what this has represented
more than anything is
the team building and
the business building.
And then specifically with the other space
is what made the acquisition
of Smosh make sense.
Again, it was like, yes,
we took the other space
because we could.
The other half of the building you mean.
Yeah, the other half of the building,
because of GMM 22, the season that we did,
the 22 minute version of GMM,
we needed more space for more people.
That only lasted one season,
but then it was like,
oh, we've got this space.
And then I think that we were like,
okay, we've done this business building,
this team building thing,
but now we got to get back to what it is
that we're going to personally create.
Not just the role, we've
created these products
like Good Mythical Morning,
or Ear Biscuits, and we
know what our role is.
And we come and we sit down
and we fulfill that role.
But what is the new thing
that we're creating?
And I think we we had a sense
that it was going to be easier for us
if we created a new space
that was a trigger for those new ideas.
And now we find ourselves
decorating our own offices
for the first time.
Once we get some furniture
in there, which is happening.
Do you have any, what do you have any idea
what you're putting in there?
I put a big shelf up because I'm like,
I think I want to put stuff on a shelf.
I think I'm gonna find stuff
that means something to me
and I'm gonna put it on the shelf.
Yeah, Jessie's getting some
shelves for some stuff.
And setting up the records
and a shout out to my
Instagram for a while back.
I put the...
You got to say shout out to LinkNeal
Shout out to LinkNeal on Instagram.
You got to actually give the plug to it.
If you wanna look at my record shelf
that's in the main living room there.
Makes me happy, makes me happy.
Yeah, well, and I'm, it's been weird
because this has been such a,
this has been another
really constricted time.
So we weren't really, I mean,
I've been going to the
creative house more than you,
but it's literally going
over to an empty house.
I mean, anything that you
saw me shoot over there,
you see I'm in a chair
in front of a blank wall.
And I'm also, I value
the creative space a lot.
But I have a very difficult
time getting motivated
to actually do the things to have like,
I don't like, okay,
put the shelf together,
put this, I don't like doing that.
I like it when it's done,
but I don't like doing it.
But I very much look forward
to what it's going to be.
I mean, we'll talk more about
this in the coming weeks,
but one of the ways
that we're exercising
our newfound creativity
is we're doing original stuff on TikTok.
That's one of the things that we're doing.
We're writing these sketches.
And getting back to this,
there's this interesting thing
that's happening on TikTok, which is,
it's not a platform that has
a partner program right now.
It has this early days
of YouTube feel to it,
where it just feels like
people who see an opportunity
on this platform and are
figuring out how to build
an audience and are trying
creative things are doing it.
And we've always approached
new platforms as,
for the past few years,
we've approached it more
as a business or as a brand.
Like what is Mythical going
to do on this platform,
usually as an extension of
what we're doing on YouTube.
But for the first time ever, and really,
this is a very fresh thing for us, I mean,
we just got a couple of things
that we've written and put up there.
We're saying like, what are we gonna do?
Like, what are Rhett and Link
going to create over there?
And it's totally different.
It's a different exercise.
But we're just beginning to be able to,
be in the house together.
Sounds like it's gonna
be decorating video.
Shelf building videos,
bike breaking videos.
Yeah, well, I'm sure we'll
talk more about that.
But yeah, I mean, it's
rounding out that space
of what we want it to be
makes it a playground for us
to then make stuff that we want to make.
And so it is a hurdle
that we're starting to clear
and I'm excited about it.
I'm interested for this space.
As employees start to come back to work.
Whenever that starts to happen,
starts working together.
It's like, what's going to happen
to open floor plans,
are we going to revert?
Everybody's talking about
how open floor plans are gonna go away.
But I mean, the Coronavirus
isn't going to be with us.
I mean, it may be with us forever,
but it's not going to be
the threat that it is even if it comes,
if it doesn't go away, it's not going
to be the threat that
it is right now forever.
I don't know, I think everyone's saying,
"We're going to reevaluate
the open workspace."
Because you know what, by the way,
people don't get any work
done in open workspaces.
That's one of the things
that I've seen people writing
is people are distracted,
and it isn't like
everyone's working together.
It's everyone's working,
and they're together.
And, I mean, I don't know
what the answer to that is.
I mean, we've designed this
space, so that it's like, okay.
And it was kind of as simple as
which employees might need to
have sensitive conversations
and/or be on the phone.
Yeah, but it's--
And those people get office.
It is interesting that we built a space
where people can connect
and be collaborative.
And that wasn't, that's not how we work.
I mean, we like to isolate ourselves
to just the two of us.
Do you remember the time when we went to--
We didn't create a bunch of,
if we would have we created for our team,
what we created for
ourselves, we would turned
that open area, not into
desks, but a big living room,
where people just lay
down on couches and stuff.
Right
You remember we went to Rocket Jump?
Was that Freddie's company?
Yeah.
Remember the first time we went there,
And I was like, where's Freddie's office?
And he just had a desk
in the middle of
everything with everybody.
Yeah.
And I remember feeling like
questioning us.
I was like, are we like--
Elitist or seperationists?
Some prima donnas, that we've
got this office in the back?
It's got a wall of what is now dead plants
because no one has been
taking care of them.
But then I was just like, no, I couldn't.
I understand the idea
of being in the middle
and being amongst everyone
but I just wouldn't get anything done.
And also me and you,
because it's not one person
it's two people who are constantly talking
through every single
thing that we're doing.
Sometimes in a heated fashion,
just whatever the
creative process entails.
You don't want to watch that.
Yeah.
You don't want to try to do other work
when that's happening
behind you, that's for sure.
You actually want to
the idea of what it's like
for us to create together
is probably better than the idea
of watching us create together.
Let's keep the mystery alive
and see the products on the other side,
but it gets pretty boring, and
monotonous, and mathematical,
in the moment, I think.
And I don't know,
up until this conversation I
hadn't really thought about,
the different types of roles here.
And it's like, people are
saying, in general, some people
are going to are going to
start working from home.
Well that's another thing.
So it's like, I haven't really,
we haven't started to
tackle that question for us.
So I'm not, I mean--
But it does change the,
both the fact that people
are working at home,
but also the fact that there's a change
in the way people are seeing open spaces,
that is changing the calculus
on how long we'll be
in this space, I think.
Because I think there has been
a part of this, just like, okay,
are we gonna need to get another space?
Are we're gonna need
to get a bigger space?
I mean, we keep growing.
But a lot of things
changed this year, I mean,
yes, there are certain jobs
that can be done from home.
Some people may actually prefer it.
There are certainly meetings
that could take place on zoom.
Does everyone really have to be here
for a all hands meeting?
Can some people join by video conference?
I think that we're going to
be answering those questions.
I've actually, yeah, and it's premature.
So I guess the last place I
want to just verbally process
is on a podcast, but
screw it, let's do it.
My first reaction,
like my knee jerk reaction is to be,
Oh, we got to get back
to the way things work
because they were working.
But it's interesting that, I don't know,
I have this as a boss, I
have this defensive stance.
It's like, well if people
start working from home,
are they really going
to get their work done?
And I don't know, I just
found myself thinking that.
But I know that there's other
ways you can answer that.
And people also work differently.
Some people can
if people work better and
thrive in that environment,
and there's easy ways to still have
accountability for your deliverables,
you know when I'm saying.
But I also think that
the work from home thing is complicated.
I think about my house.
Oh, yeah.
But a lot of our
employees, they don't have
two or three kids running around.
Well, not only that.
Some of them do, but most of them don't.
It would be a different
equation if I was a single guy,
or if Jessie and I just
had Barbara and no kids.
'Cause we talked about the spaces
that have meant so much to us.
It's like, I bet you if I visited
some of my employees
unannounced, I'd be like,
"Well they've, this room is a,
"they've created a creative
space for themselves.
Well it's funny, I didn't
think about mentioning this.
But we've been talking about
how long are we going
to stay in this house?
Like we're doing that work outside
and we've had this open
construction pit forever.
Hopefully it'll be done in a month or two.
But it's like, how long we're
gonna stay in this house?
Are we gonna stay here till
Shepherd goes to college?
That's another at least seven years.
And I think we're kind
of leaning towards that.
But Jessie and I have
been talking about like,
okay, as you get older and
as you live in a space,
you just start answering
a lot of questions
like, what do we want in a home?
But I still don't think we understood
what we really wanted in a home.
And I'm very happy with our house.
But there's a number of
things, like just the idea
of finding a place, you
can't really get away
'cause our house is very open.
And even in this little
guest house, guest room
that is basically Jessie's office,
but also our guest bedroom.
It's very close to everything.
It's like, everyone who
comes down the stairs,
every conversation that's in the kitchen.
And I told Jessie, I was like,
I don't know what our next home will have.
But, I'll be 50 probably
when we're moving into it,
and I just have always had this idea
That when I get to be an old man,
which I'm approaching that very quickly,
I just want to have one of those offices
that's kind of dark,
there's a lot of wood.
And it's away from everything.
And maybe there's like
a long hallway to it.
I mean, they don't make
houses like this anymore.
But I just have this vision
of just being able to just
have a retreat in my own home.
And I probably won't even
need it by that point,
because my kids won't be there.
Yeah, you're talking about a panic room.
I'm just talking about
one of those offices
like you see in a movie,
with a bunch of books that
you don't read behind you.
Yeah, okay.
Space is important,
whether it's a cubicle,
a little corner of your bedroom,
where, if you can, it
doesn't have to be big.
It doesn't have to be like
Rhett's talking about,
at the end of the hallway,
where you get tired
by the time you get
there, and so your kids
will never bother you
with their bike problems.
I can read between the lines there.
Hmm, okay.
I think everybody's got
to have a little nook.
If you got a little nook
that's like this is my little space.
I used to go, in my room I
would go inside my closet,
and I had a little space in my closet
where I would just go in there and sit,
and it just felt like this is my space.
My closet was too dirty.
I would go in the attic.
I had a clean little
space in my closet, man.
There was a box full of foam.
I don't know what this
foam was for, or from,
but I would get into
that box full of foam.
You'd get inside of the box?
Yeah.
It was open top.
Yeah, see you're little cozy spot, man.
If you take anything
from this conversation,
take that, take finding a little cozy.
Find your box full of foam.
No, but I think just practically,
especially for those of you
who are in a creative field
I do think that it's important
to just ask the question,
what is your space?
How is your space contributing
to what you're trying to create?
Because, I mean, we look back
and we got into a little
bit of the detail,
but I just think that so much
of what we happened to
be creating at the time
was largely dictated by the decision
that we had made about the space.
And that's why it's gotten,
it's very important to us,
and that's why we were quick.
Once we realized, well not too quick,
maybe it took a year or two to realize,
once we realized that this
space had become representative
of one side of our jobs,
we needed to push into the other side,
the thing that drives this whole thing.
So think about that creative people.
And I got a rec for you.
Rec baby, rec baby, one, two, three, four.
I Highly recommend
watching 13th on Netflix.
Just to continue the
conversation of racial equality
and the Black Lives Matter
movement, and again,
keeping that as an
active part of our lives
is important to us.
This is not just, this can't just be
a flash in the pan for us
personal, is what we've discussed.
We want to be actively engaged
as part of the solution
and not bystanders.
And there's lots of
recommendations floating around.
This has been one of them that
I watched, this documentary.
I'll read the summary.
"Filmmaker Ava DuVernay
explores the history
"of racial inequality
in the United States.
"Focusing on the fact
that the nation's prisons
"are disproportionately filled
with African Americans."
It was released in October of 2016.
But it, I didn't know that
when I will watched it.
And I was like, man,
they got this out quick.
And that's just ignorance,
that I would find myself
thinking that, it's so
important for this movement now.
But, I mean, again, it's
like I embarrass myself
left and right with the
things that I think because
I just have not been
educated and engaged enough.
But this documentary is,
I mean 97% on Rotten
Tomatoes, very well done.
And it gives you an overview of
the dark side, the ramifications
of the criminal justice
system for black Americans.
And how it's set up, it connects the dots.
Yeah, 'cause I think a
really important aspect
of all of this is,
and this is something that has,
that I didn't really
understand for a long time,
and it was reading some black authors
who explained this to me,
is just understanding that there,
yes, in 2020, there continue to be
a lot of policies,
whether it's within our
criminal justice system,
whether it's within our voting system,
our political system, there are policies
that if you're me, you didn't
understand why they're racist.
Right, I mean, you talk about Nixon
and his, really planting the seeds
for the war on drugs from the Reagan era.
And he's talking about
being the law and order president.
Right.
I mean, which is exactly what
Trump is talking about now.
Yeah, yeah, when you see the history.
They are intentionally
using the same language
in order to accomplish what they want.
Right, and there's a way as a white person
you think about these things,
'cause I was that white person
who thought about these things.
And I was like, well, we talked
about this two years ago.
It was like, okay, voter
ID laws, that's not racist.
That's just having somebody,
just requiring somebody
to have an ID to vote,
how can that be racist?
But then when you understand
the history of that approach,
and who is being targeted,
and what is being prevented.
And it isn't fraud, is actually
certain groups of people
being prevented from voting.
And once you understand
the intention behind it,
you're like, oh, that is
why that's a racist policy.
When you talk about the war on drugs,
it's like how could that be bad?
I mean, how could, just say no, be bad?
And when you look at
the policies in place,
for the punishments
associated with crack--
Versus cocaine.
Versus cocaine. Yeah.
Which are the same thing
but they're prevalent
in different communities,
white community versus
the black community?
Well, specifically, it was
five grams of crack gave
the equivalent prison sentence
of 500 grams of cocaine.
And that was strictly because
cocaine was a white drug
and crack was a black drug.
And again, all this stuff was happening
when we were growing up.
We were growing up in a
little small town where
we just thought that everybody's
got equal opportunity.
I mean, the civil rights
movement happened years ago,
everybody's, everything's equal now.
And once you start realizing that
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, it's not.
It's not and that's the fight
that is being fought right now.
And it is a fight to change policy.
It is a fight to change racist policy.
And if you don't think
that racist policy exists,
then I would, my argument would be
you're not paying attention.
And so you got--
Just watch it, I'm saying watch 13th.
13th is a great place to start.
Yeah.
It lays it all out and
gives you something to,
you don't have to agree with everything,
to be exposed, to educate
yourself, to be exposed to it
and then reach your own
conclusions but I think
it's very well made and it
was very eye opening for me.
Okay, well we're back.
We're here, we're in the studio.
We're at the round table of dim lighting
and if all goes according to plan,
we will be here again next week.
Who knows?
What are plans?
#EarBiscuits.
Love ya.
To watch more Ear Biscuits
click on the playlist on the right
[ Rhett Voiceover] To
watch the previous episode
of Ear Biscuits click on
the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast.
It's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.